hello everyone and welcome back to
Vancouver Canada it's a game two of the
1971 semi-final match between bent
Larsen and the Bobby Fischer now as
you've seen in game number one it was
really a masterpiece played by both
players
unfortunately for Larson he missed that
Bishop to c5 idea which was a brilliant
follow up on Fischer's rook captures on
e5 and if you check out the article I
told you to check out in my previous
video then you know that Ben Flores and
said that he will defeat Bobby Fischer
that he will win the candidates and that
he will become world champion of course
he has to beat Spassky to do that that
he will you know put so much pressure
against fishery in the early games that
Fischer will simply crack under pressure
so things definitely are not going the
way he planned the Fischer won Game one
brilliantly
now Larsen has the white pieces and it's
a very interesting it's it's really an
excellent game one that can be easily
overlooked when checking out all of the
games of the match and thank you
everyone for sharing the information
about Robert Rubin in the comments of my
previous video as we did mention I I
didn't know why he resigned the match
after only losing one game to Tigran
Petrosian but if you haven't read in the
comments already it seems that the
audience in Seville where the match was
played was extremely loud and Hoonah
really couldn't take it so he lost he
was in time trouble and he couldn't face
the noise from the audience he blundered
blunder one move and Petros in one game
number seven but the noise wasn't all
that much problem for Tigran Petrosian
because Petrosyan had a hearing aid and
then he just you know turned it down and
the noise didn't bother
Petrosyan so I mean seems like not all
that much to resign a whole match for
but you just lost with the white pieces
against Petrosyan next game the next
game Tigran Petrosian will have the
white pieces and if Petrosyan wishes it
I'm sure Petrosyan can easily draw all
the games so I don't I guess it's
justified but yeah we'll we'll check out
into that a bit more but that's
everything you said in the comments so
about this game let's check out this
nice photo we don't have a lot of them
but those we do we're gonna
we're gonna check them out so let's see
what happened here Larsen had the white
pieces and he opened with c4 so okay the
English opening he prepared we have c5
Bobby replies with the symmetrical
variation 9 f3 g 6 and d4 C capture some
d4 Knight captures in the now comes
Knight to c6 we have E 4 here and with
this efore move Larsen transposes the
game the game transposed into the
Sicilian defense the accelerated dragon
variation which is a bit odd for for
Fischer to allow this well not odd but
as you know official rarely played the
dragon well never and he said about the
dragon and the Pierce defense that it's
not a really good opening for black you
know why can't simply push in G for h4
h5 and win the game so it's very
interesting that Fischer allows this no
doubt that he prepared something nice
for Larsson nice to have six Knight to
c3 and now d6 this is standard theory of
the Dragon Bishop to e2 Knight capture
son d4 Queen captures on d4 and now
Bishop to g7 and here Bishop to g5 by
Larsson it seems like a dangerous move
allowing this idea here but you don't
really have any good discoveries for
example not h5 i all simply move the
Queen and that white will still still
achieve this nice Queen Bishop battery
where he can exchange all the dark
square bishop and you will simply have a
funny night on h5 okay blush up to g5
will have h6 asking worse and what he
wants to do with the bishop and Bishop
to e3 and now castles Larson goes back
Queen to d2 with the temple against dh6
pawn queen a king to h7 defending and
now we have castles and here Bishop to
e6
an interesting move by Fisher which
Larson will immediately try to punish f4
so okay we have roped the c8 with a
double attack against the c4 pawn b3
enter now comes Queen to a5 a very nice
move pressures this knight on c3 if the
knight have removes then the bishop will
also be attacking it and also the Queen
is kind of keeping an eye on the f5
square but but not really which you'll
see in a moment here Larson pushes a3 we
have a sec
and now comes f5 and the Larsen's f5
idea is more than justified because here
if you play G captures he captures now
you cannot play Bishop captures because
the rook can simply capture the bishop
and you see now that the Queen's defense
of DF v square is only imaginary because
if Queen captures Bishop to d3
I will win the Queen Knight can't block
because this Knight is also guarding the
d4 square so here you would simply lose
the Queen and the game so after this f5
move Fisher goes Bishop to d7 and now we
have B for attacking Fisher's Queen so
now Fischer can either go Queen to e5
which is a pretty pretty dangerous thing
to do because Queen will not have all
that many squares to go to or he can go
back Queen to c7 but then the Queen will
kind of be out of the game so Fisher
decides to go Queen e5 you know straight
to the middle of the board we have rook
81 offering the d4 pawn here but
Larsen's the so-called sacrifice of the
point is justified because you can't
really capture it if you play the Knight
captures simply Knight captures Queen
captures now comes rook to f4 forcing
the Queen to go all the way back to c6
Bishop the f3 now attacking the Queen
Queen Queen goes back and now rook to h4
with a powerful attack against the black
King which would in the end proved to be
decisive
so okay rook a to e1 Fischer goes Bishop
to c6 he simply increases the pressure
against the backwards E for pawn we have
Bishop to f4 a very nice idea by Larsson
Bishop to f3 was also possible for
example simply defending the e4 pawn so
here of course you cannot capture with
the bishop if you capture with the
bishop then Bishop to d4 will trap
Fisher's Queen but you could try
capturing with the night but then you
simply get again Knight captures Bishop
captures Bishop captures Queen captures
and now again this rook to a4 idea where
you simply kick the Queen back all the
way to c6 and now rook to h4 will again
be a very nice attack against the black
king so ok after this Bishop to c6 move
Larson goes for Bishop to f4 so it seems
that
Fischer's queen is trapped but it's very
unlikely the Fischer would wander a
queen on move 19 in a world candidate
series so
of course he had everything calculated
he goes Knight captures on e4 now this
comes with an attack on Larsen's queen
Knight captures on e4 and now Queen
captures on e4 and here you have to
decide what to do Larsson play the
Bishop to d3 which is the best move
Bishop to f3 not not as much because
this will lose you a pawn after Queen to
d4 Czech Queen captures the Bishop
captures with Czech Bishop to e3
characters captures and now captures on
f3 rook captures and now not capturing
here because you're each 7.7 but rook to
c7 defending the other rook can come
here always well and Fischer keeps his
extra point here
so after this Queenie four move Bishop
to d3 would an attack against Fischer's
Queen also now there while the bishop
was here there was the threat of course
of Queen captures and g2 this stops both
threats and the forces Fischer screen to
move Queen 34 with check we have King to
h1 and now rook CT 8 as the 7 bone was
under attack Bishop to e3 attacking
force Queen we have Queen to c3 here
Fischer has to allow capturing of his
pawn because the Queen doesn't really
have anywhere to go so Bishop captures
you cannot capture a bishop because the
Queen will be hanging we have Queen
captures on d2 Bishop captures and now
Bishop to e5 Bishop to f4 Bishop
captures rook captures G captures on f5
and this might well we could say that
this is the critical moment of the game
in this position Larsson care I played
rook captures an f5 but it will be only
after the game and you know many many
well not years but I don't know when was
the official analysis that the bent
Larsen said that he could have won the
game in this position which I'm not all
that sure that it stands because okay
rook captures an F I was played in the
game he later suggested rook to e3
but then after rook to g8 you have
Bishop captures on f5 King to h6 and now
not rook to h3 but rather bash of to h3
if rook to h3 and this is a very
interesting move because now if Fisher
goes King to g7 then white can easily
win the game here and although this is
only
sideline feel free to pause the video
here and find the winning idea because
it's quite quite enjoyable
I'll give it a couple of seconds if you
want to decide whether to do it or not
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations it's it's really a
nice tactic and you're you are a great
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
Bishop to e6 is the move what's the idea
well now you're threatening rook
captures on f7 and also if pawn captures
then you simply play rook the g3 check
King has to go to the H file doesn't
really matter where our rook to h4 will
be checkmate and on the other hand even
if you don't capture for example if you
play f5 doesn't really matter
rook the g3 comes you move now comes
rock captures and the bishop is guarding
the rook captures captures your upper
rope you're winning this game but it's
it doesn't really work because after
King to h6 you don't have to go after
Luke to h3 check you can simply go King
g5 and now all is well
or the rook is under attack you move the
rook here comes c6 and all is well now
rook g3 check you move rook checks to
move rook checks you move captures
captures and now the bishop simply has
to move and black is perfectly fine here
so what Larsen's idea was after this
King to h6 move is rather a Bishop to h3
and now after King after King comes to
after rook the g7 defending the f7 pawn
now be five characters captures the
bishop has to keep an eye on the Jie du
Pont so Bishop to d5 and here Larson
said that this rogue to h4 check came
here and now look the d4 the bishop has
nowhere to go
well of course you can go to e6 but here
you would lose a pawn and here after all
is said and done
Larson would be up upon so this was a an
idea Larson mentions but still if this
is winning you know perhaps it is
perhaps not it's it's hard to say a lot
of a lot of things can be said about
this position but ok it was not played
in the game after gf5 rook characters
and if I was played by Larson now
threatening all sorts of discoveries you
know as the bishop is eyeing the King on
h7 so a king to g7 we have looked to g5
check King moves with an attack on the
rook and H for now and
okay Larsen really got has Fisher's King
in the corner here so each six by Fisher
group 2f1 threatening rook to f6 and now
of course f5 rook to e1 and now
preparing to pile up on the e6 pawn and
now comes Roop to f7 preparing to
perhaps double up on the e-file also
while this rook is busy guarding the e6
pawn official would like to play rook to
g7 to exchange his rook for Larsen's
super active rook b5 here we have pawn
captures pawn captures and now Bishop
back to d7 G for again a very nice idea
now of course if you capture you get the
membership g6 you were to lose the
exchange here so after g4 rook to 88 a
very nice move by Fischer G captures an
f5 e captures an f5 and here
what would a move like rook e 2g one a
Larson has more than more than play
activity here to at least draw the game
here and you know all would be well
probably for him and this could still be
anyone's game but after this he captures
an f5 move he played Bishop to c4
slightly improving the position before
deciding what to do next perhaps perhaps
his idea was moving moving the rock to
g1 after this move but it's hard to say
but this move allows Fischer a move that
Larsson did not expect here
of course Fischer's rook on f7 is under
attack but Fischer did not become world
champion by moving his rook when his
opponents intact it so feel free to
pause the video here and find the only
move that loves Fischer to go to push
for some advantage in this position
I'll give it a you know feel free to you
know study the position somewhere and
remember a lot since the move was Bishop
to c4 so a Fischer's move it really
takes advantage of this move so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are definitely not a
rope mover and for those who just want
to enjoy the show
rook to a4 well okay you did move the
rook but not the one that was attacked
so what you do here okay if Bishop
captures on f7 rook capture
in 84 would check so this is basically
the idea King moves wherever ever
do you wanna orgy - and now King captor
series just one upon so the idea is
really that simple after Bishop to c4
rook to a for you you attack the
undefended bishop on c4 so here
Larson played rook to c1 which is not
which is a you know capturing
immediately on f7 and allowing the the
loss of one point was better than the
the move Larsson played here because he
must have over looked this move so okay
Bishop character son b5 and now there
there's nothing to do here here if you
capture the bishop now then comes rogue
captures on h4 with the same idea you
lose the exchange now which is even
worse captures captures which check you
move and then King captures here it's
the rooks against a bishop and a rook
and two pawns up completely winning so
here after Bishop captures on b5 Larsen
only now captured on f7 and we have rook
captures on h4 with check King to g2 and
knocking cappers on g5 Fischer is now up
two points and of course this is now
completely winning it's only a matter of
how Fischer will you know take advantage
of his two extra points okay Bishop to
d5 attacking the b7 pawn bishop laser
simply defending there's no breaking
through here rook to d1 we have rook to
a for Bishop to f3 now threatening the
d6 pawn but Fischer doesn't mind
captures captures now it's two points
against zero points again completely
winning rook to a to check King moves
came to f4 now improving the position of
the King Bishop g2
rook to be to look to d7 now and now
simply start pushing G or your passport
Rock to d8 we have Bishop to e2 and now
push up to h3 Bishop to g4 of course
Larsen cannot afford to the trade pieces
here Bishop to f1 and now Bishop to f3
we have rook to b8 push up to e4 making
room for the king we have bushel place X
and the now King to e3 and now Fischer
is Bishop and King really make make way
for this best f1 to become Queen rook to
c8 we have
hope to be one check King 2h2 and now
comes King to a four and here it doesn't
matter what Larsson plays now Fisher is
no longer interested in promoting this
pawn but rather Larson is getting
checkmated here regardless of what place
if you play something well whatever then
you get a rock to H 1 this will be
checkmate because the bishop is guarding
the G to square the King is guarding the
G 3 square so there's really no no way
out of this whatever you play you can
you can give up a couple of pieces with
Bishop to F 1 Roxy 1 but there is no
defense whatsoever against rook 2 h 1
checkmate so yeah this is game number
two of the 1971 semi-final match between
bent Larsen and Bobby Fischer I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you're enjoying
the Bobby Fischer series so far it's
very interesting after well this was
something Mikhail Botvinnik said after
the match but he said that it's very
easy to understand how Fischer won every
game against the mark time on off and
also it's very easy to understand how he
won games against the bent Larsen but
how he won
well how he want with such a drastic
margin that was that never ever happened
before in chess history that isn't all
that easy to explain now but we'll get
back to that and we're going to talk
about that some more after we finish the
series
I would like to thank Felipe Castro
Cardona Christopher Drake Chris Thorpe
taneli Lauren only and the Dennis
Tomlinson for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another game from the Bobby Fischer
series Larsen vs. Fischer game 3 thank
you all and I'll see you soon